So this was a comment on one of my reels
about being a stay at home wife and mother
and like, you know,
being the keeper of a home and being just at home. And I.
I want to address this one
because I feel like it's a really common misconception
that a lot of people have
that if you are like
that trad wife or mom
that you basically
all you're allowed to do is stay home.
Literally. Like,
you really don't do anything with your life.
You just. You're at home all the time
and you're with your kids
and you're doing housework 24 7. And, um,
that's really not true.
Um, I. I'm a stay at home mom.
I have four kids.
I don't have like,
a career or job outside of the home,
but I do. I, um,
design dresses and sell them.
And having that creative outlet is really huge
and helping me to not become overwhelmed with, um.
With that mundaneness that you can experience
of doing the same thing every day.
And so, yeah, it.
I totally understand what this lady saying
that it can be depressing
if all you do is you just stay home
because you think that's what you have to do to be.
I tried wife or whatever.
Um, but yeah, I mean,
I guess where the line is for me is
if I am doing anything that
puts my husband or my kids on the back burner
and They're not first in my life.
Then that's where I draw the line
and be like, okay,
I'm not gonna do that anymore.
And I feel like if I did try to do a career,
um, my husband and my kids,
it would be very hard
to give them first priority in my life.
So anyways, I just, um,
wanted to put that out there
that being a stay at home mom is not.
Does not mean you're cooped up all the time.
You definitely should have some kind of
creative outlets.
You should go places and do things.
You should get a babysitter every now and again
and go have fun.
I mean, yeah,
it doesn't mean that you're
cooped up at home all the time.
So I just wanted to clear that up.